When Mark was 15, his father was shot. And he reacted like a 15-year-old. He went up to each of his relatives, to anybody who'd listen actually, and he declared, someday, when he grows up, he would become a pro football player, and he would find the men who shot his father.
马克15岁那年，他的父亲遭枪杀。他的反应就像个15岁的孩子。他走到每一位亲戚面前，实际上是走到任何愿意听他说话的人面前，宣称等他长大后，一定会成为职业橄榄球运动员，并找出杀害他父亲的凶手。
When I look back at that kid, that 15-year-old kid making that promise, it's pathetic in a way.
如今回想起那个许下诺言的15岁孩子，某种程度上觉得他很可怜。
Well, it's such a particular vision of what a pro football player is, which is to say, as a kid, you're trying to conjure the notion of somebody who's very powerful, but also pure somehow.
嗯，这是一种对职业橄榄球运动员非常独特的设想，也就是说，作为一个孩子，你试图构想出一个既非常强大，又在某种程度上纯洁无瑕的人。
Yes. And I remember even then some friends saying, now, Mark, pro football is kind of a lofty goal. Just maybe high school football. Years later when I reflected back on that, I thought, geez, the kid's dad just was killed. Why disabuse him of some vision he's got?
是的。我记得那时甚至有些朋友说：“嘿，马克，职业橄榄球是个遥不可及的目标。也许只是高中橄榄球吧。”多年后我反思这一点时，我想，天哪，这孩子的父亲刚刚遇害。为什么要打破他心中仅存的某种憧憬呢？
Mike's dad was a bar owner in Fresno, California. Two men came into the bar, played a game of pool, ordered two beers, then came into the back room and shot him. They didn't take any money. It was a gangland-style hit. And there was talk that Mark's father must be caught up with organized crime. So at 15, Mark started calling around until his mother made him stop. Seventeen years later, he moved back to Fresno. By this time, he was a reporter for the LA Times , and he wanted to write a book investigating his dad's murder. He was so skittish that he and his wife got their home under assumed names, did not tell people where they lived.
迈克的父亲是加州弗雷斯诺的一名酒吧老板。两名男子进入酒吧，打了一局台球，点了两杯啤酒，然后走进后室枪杀了他。他们没有拿走任何钱。这是一场黑帮式的暗杀。当时有传言说马克的父亲一定与有组织犯罪有关。所以马克15岁时开始四处打听，直到他母亲制止了他。十七年后，他搬回了弗雷斯诺。此时，他已是《洛杉矶时报》的一名记者，他想写一本书调查他父亲的谋杀案。他当时非常警惕，以至于他和妻子用化名租房，不告诉别人他们住在哪里。
It's hard to make sense of all that, but there was a great deal of paranoia. I didn't want family to really know what I was doing. And I thought that if there was some way to-- if someone got nervous about the questions I was asking, I wanted to make it difficult for them to try to find me. And I remember changing my sleep patterns so that I was awake all through the night, and I was guarding the house. I had actually a gun that I had under the couch. I was sleeping on the couch. In a way, I became very childlike again. I really had to become a 15-year-old again in some ways to get at this thing.
很难理解这一切，但当时确实存在极大的偏执。我不想让家人真正知道我在做什么。我想，如果有人对我提出的问题感到紧张，我想让他们很难找到我。我记得我改变了作息规律，整夜保持清醒，在守护着房子。我实际上在沙发下藏了一把枪。我就睡在沙发上。在某种程度上，我又变得非常孩子气了。为了探究这件事，我在某些方面真的必须变回一个15岁的孩子。
Like how do you mean?
你是怎么个意思？
Well, I think it wasn't terribly adult to try to think that you could come back to your hometown and try to hide your identity. I don't think that was really adult.
嗯，我想试图回到家乡并隐瞒自己的身份，这并不算特别成熟。我不认为那真的是成年人的做法。
When somebody close to us dies, part of us can remain suspended there at the moment it happened. And we stay there. Part of us stays there, turning the whole thing over and over in our heads. Mark spent three years talking to informants about his father's murder. He went through police files, analyzed phone records, and in the end found credible evidence that his father was murdered, just as he was about to blow the whistle on a drug ring, one with local police on its side, Mark believes. He wrote his book about it. It's called In My Father's Name. And still that was not enough. He's still not at peace.
当与我们亲近的人去世时，我们的一部分可能会停留在事情发生的那一刻。我们停留在那里。我们的一部分留在了那里，在脑海中一遍又一遍地回味整件事。马克花了三年时间与线人谈论他父亲的谋杀案。他查阅了警方档案，分析了通话记录，最终发现了可信的证据，证明他的父亲就是在准备举报一个贩毒集团时被谋杀的，马克认为该集团有当地警察撑腰。他为此写了一本书。书名是《以我父亲的名义》。但即便如此还是不够。他依然无法获得平静。
Have I been liberated by some of those answers? I don't know if liberation is the right word.
我是否因为那些答案而得到了解脱？我不知道“解脱”这个词是否准确。
But why? What would it take?
但为什么呢？需要什么才能做到？
I think there's a part of me that wants to sit across from the men who set this whole thing up and talk to them about it.
我想我内心深处有一个部分，想与那些策划这一切的人面对面坐下来，和他们谈谈这件事。
You want them to admit it to your face.
你想让他们当面承认。
Yeah, that's right. That's what I want them to do. I have played over that encounter with the killers so many times. And one of things that I would tell them going in is it goes no further than you and me. This is it. I want to ask you one question. Were you responsible for the murder of my father?
是的，没错。这就是我想要他们做的。我无数次在脑海中重演过与凶手的那场邂逅。如果真的见面，我要告诉他们的第一件事就是：这件事到你我为止。就是这样。我想问你一个问题。你是谋杀我父亲的凶手吗？
And so actually, you've actually imagined this over and over to yourself.
所以，你其实已经在脑海中反复想象过这个场景了。
Oh, I've imagined it all the time.
哦，我一直都在想象。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm IRA Glass. Today on our program, people trying to make sense out of things for which they'll never get answers or real peace. All three stories in our program today are about people facing the idea of death and telling themselves one thing about it or another. And is there anything that can be said? Is there anything that can comfort us in that situation?
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和公共广播国际的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是：人们试图理解那些永远无法获得答案或真正平静的事情。今天节目中的三个故事都是关于人们面对死亡的概念，并对自己讲述着这样或那样的故事。有什么话可以安慰我们吗？在那种情况下，有什么能慰藉我们吗？
Act One of our program, The Disappearance, trying to comprehend what it means when people are there, alive in your life one day, and the next, gone. Act Two, Look for the Union Label. The plot of this story sounds on the surface, I have to say, like the script of the worst sitcom ever made. A father and daughter sit down together for no real reason, just a whim really, to write his obituary, not really thinking about what it means. And then at some point, someone starts to think about what it means. Act Three, Take My Wife, Please. Can dwelling morbidly on future disaster striking your own family, can that actually be healthy? One brave man defends the idea. Stay with us.
节目的第一幕，《消失》，试图理解当人们某一天还在你的生活中鲜活地存在，而下一刻却突然离去时意味着什么。第二幕，《寻找工会标签》。这个故事的情节表面上听起来，我必须说，就像有史以来最糟糕的情景喜剧剧本。一对父女坐在一起，没有任何真正的原因，纯粹是一时兴起，写他的讣告，并没有真正思考这意味着什么。然后到了某个时刻，有人开始思考这意味着什么。第三幕，《带上我的妻子，拜托》。沉溺于未来可能降临到自己家庭的灾难，这真的健康吗？一位勇敢的男士捍卫了这个想法。请继续收听。
Act One, The Disappearance. One of the most remarkable books that I've read in a while is by a woman named Genevieve Jurgensen, about her husband Laurent and she lost their two daughters, Elise and Mathilde, at the ages of four and seven. The book is a series of letters that she wrote to her friend 12 years after their deaths.
第一幕，《消失》。我最近读到的一本非常了不起的书，作者是一位叫吉纳维芙·尤根森的女性，关于她的丈夫劳伦特，他们失去了两个女儿，埃莉斯和马蒂尔德，分别只有四岁和七岁。这本书是她在她们去世12年后写给她朋友的一系列信件。
And one of the things that's so remarkable about it is how she still struggles. She doesn't want to keep suffering over their deaths, but suffering over them is the last way that she has to love them. She's also keenly aware that she wants them to seem, in these letters, to be more than just names. When you tell a story about somebody, it's sometimes hard for them to seem more like just a character in a story, and she keeps trying over and over to find ways to make it real, that, in fact, they were alive. They are more than can be expressed on the page.
其中最引人注目的一点是，她依然在挣扎。她不想继续为她们的去世而痛苦，但为她们受苦是她爱她们的最后方式。她也敏锐地意识到，在这些信件中，她想让她们显得不仅仅是个名字。当你讲述关于某人的故事时，有时很难让他们看起来不仅仅是故事里的角色，她一次又一次地尝试寻找方法让这一切变得真实，即事实上，她们曾经活过。她们远不止是书页上所能表达的那些。
You never knew our daughters. Neither did you know me as I was when they were alive. I will have to tell you everything. Can one really tell someone about very young children? I will not even show you photographs of them. All they show are two little girls, barely distinguishable from each other, just like all the little blond children which people primary school classes in the beaches along the Atlantic coast in the summer.
你从未见过我们的女儿。你也不知道她们活着时我是什么样子。我必须告诉你一切。真的有人能向别人讲述非常年幼的孩子吗？我甚至不会给你看她们的照片。照片上显示的只是两个小女孩，几乎无法区分，就像大西洋沿岸海滩上那些在夏天挤满小学班级的金发小孩子一样。
On the 29th of April 1980, the official photographer for the school which my daughters attended came to take some class photographs. They were both dead the next day. Indeed, we did not receive these photographs until several weeks after the news of our solitude. Mathilde's class is in uniform, so it is a picture of a little girl in navy blue in a row, stifling her giggles in between her best friends. Elise, who was still in the nursery class, is wearing the dress with the sailor collar that my mother gave her. She's sitting in the first row, looking solemnly at the lens. I think that in this picture, she's really very like me.
1980年4月29日，我女儿所在学校的官方摄影师来拍摄班级合影。第二天她们就都去世了。确实，直到我们收到孤独的消息几周后，我们才收到这些照片。马蒂尔德的班级穿着制服，所以这是一张一个穿着海军蓝衣服的小女孩坐在排里，在好朋友之间忍住咯咯笑的照片。还在上幼儿园的埃莉斯，穿着我母亲给她的那件带水手领的裙子。她坐在第一排，庄重地看着镜头。我觉得在这张照片里，她真的很像我。
In Mathilde's satchel, I still have her school overall with her name embroidered on it, with its ink stains and biscuit crumbs in the pockets. In her exercise book, in her childish but careful handwriting, she has written the date, which will be the date of her death and the death of her little sister. Wednesday, 30th of April 1980.
在马蒂尔德的书包里，我还留着她绣着名字的校服罩衫，口袋里还有墨水渍和饼干屑。在她的练习本上，用她稚嫩但细心的笔迹，她写下了日期，那将是她和她小妹妹去世的日期。1980年4月30日，星期三。
What else can I tell you? I would like you to have heard me talking to them just once, even if only on the telephone. I feel powerless in trying to make you accept this evidence. They were here. I was their mother.
我还能告诉你什么？我希望你曾听过我和她们说话，哪怕只有一次，哪怕只是在电话里。在试图让你接受这个事实时，我感到无力。她们曾经在这里。我是她们的母亲。
I went to pick them up at school. We stopped at the supermarket to buy two cheap waxed coats, one in red, one in blue. And I dropped them off with my mother, not before playing a practical joke on her on the landing. I bundled my daughters up in the coats with the hoods up, pulled tightly over their noses and tied under their chins. They rang the bell, and I hid, and my mother pretended not to recognize them. Then I went home because I was a speech therapist at the time, and I had patients waiting. My sister-in-law came, as intended, to pick Mathilde and Elise up to take them to their other grandmother, but they never arrived because they died toward the end of the afternoon about 10 meters from each other on the side of the northern highway.
我去学校接她们。我们在超市停下来买了件廉价的打蜡外套，一件红色，一件蓝色。我把她们送到我母亲那里，在此之前还在楼道里跟她开了个玩笑。我把女儿们裹在外套里，兜帽拉得紧紧的，盖住鼻子，在下巴下系好。她们按响了门铃，我躲了起来，我母亲假装不认识她们。然后我回家了，因为我当时是言语治疗师，我有病人等着。我的嫂子按计划来接马蒂尔德和埃莉斯去见她们的另一个祖母，但她们从未到达，因为她们在下午快结束时，在北部高速公路边距离彼此约10米的地方去世了。
I'm hesitating about what to write next. There is no common ground between before and after. Or at least what they have in common strikes me as just as painful to excavate as the most deeply buried relics of before. Yes, I'm hesitating. I'm afraid of failing. I'm afraid that you will believe more readily in their death than in their lives.
我犹豫着接下来要写什么。在“之前”和“之后”之间没有共同点。或者至少它们共同拥有的东西，在我看来，挖掘起来和最深埋的“之前”遗迹一样痛苦。是的，我在犹豫。我害怕失败。我害怕你会更容易相信她们的死亡，而不是她们的生命。
A few years ago, I still used to drive out into the countryside and bellow at the top of my lungs: Mathilde! I was really calling her. Of course, she did not come. At least I had spoken her name once more. Sometimes I meet a little girl who has the same name as her, and I speak it. I say, hello, Mathilde, goodbye, Mathilde, with a smile. And I think, help.
几年前，我还会开车去乡下，扯着嗓子大喊：马蒂尔德！我真的是在呼唤她。当然，她没有来。至少我又呼唤了一次她的名字。有时我会遇到一个和她同名的小女孩，我会叫她。我说，你好，马蒂尔德，再见，马蒂尔德，带着微笑。我想，救命。
On the eve of that May Day holiday, we were not expecting anyone to call, and the ringing of the telephone awakened no feelings in us. We lifted the receiver without curiosity. A slight rustling on the line indicated that the call was being made from outside Paris. My sister? No, I knew she was on her way to Paris.
五一劳动节前夕，我们没指望任何人会打电话，电话铃声也没有引起我们的任何情绪。我们毫无好奇心地拿起了听筒。线路上传来一阵轻微的沙沙声，表明电话是从巴黎以外打来的。我姐姐吗？不，我知道她正在去巴黎的路上。
An unfamiliar man's voice checked that we were indeed the people he was looking for. Then he told us to hold the line. The next voice was that of our brother-in-law, Christian, who had left with his wife, their baby, and our two girls. We asked him how he was. He said that he was not good at all, that they had had a very serious car accident. We said yes, and? He told us our two little girls were dead.
一个陌生的男声确认了我们确实是他要找的人。然后他叫我们不要挂断。下一个声音是我们妹夫克里斯蒂安的，他带着他的妻子、他们的婴儿和我们的两个女孩出发了。我们问他怎么样。他说他一点也不好，他们发生了一起非常严重的车祸。我们说，是的，然后呢？他告诉我们，我们的两个小女儿去世了。
We thought he was playing a joke on us and then thought no one would play a joke in such poor taste. Laurent said, but Christian, it's not true. He fell to his knees, calling his children. I asked for news of the others. Everyone was fine. Where did we have to go? To the hospital at Peronne. I did not know where it was. Christian give us a few directions. Laurent knew. We hung up.
我们以为他在跟我们开玩笑，然后想到没有人会开这种品位极差的玩笑。劳伦特说，但克里斯蒂安，这不是真的。他跪倒在地，呼唤着他的孩子们。我询问其他人的消息。每个人都很好。我们要去哪里？去佩罗内的医院。我不知道那在哪里。克里斯蒂安给我们指了路。劳伦特知道。我们挂断了电话。
I immediately felt how impossible it was to raise myself to the scale of this event. The terror mounted in me out of all proportion to my own dimensions. I could not contain it all. I was still this little woman in her little apartment next to a little man in the same little apartment. The terror targeted us exclusively. We were its only prey, it's only destination, the terminus. It was a giant, and we were dwarves.
我立刻感到，将自己提升到这一事件的规模是多么不可能。恐惧在我心中升起，与我个人的维度完全不成比例。我无法容纳这一切。我依然是她那间小公寓里的小女人，旁边是同一个小公寓里的小男人。恐惧专门针对我们。我们是它唯一的猎物，唯一的目的地，终点站。它是巨人，而我们是侏儒。
Laurent took me by the wrists and asked me not to scream. He said, "To think we're going to have to get over this." A big part of us has stayed there forever. I will tell you what happened next, everything you want to know about what happened next. But at the moment, I cannot. Just as then, I am looking for the link between my daughters and that news.
劳伦特抓着我的手腕，让我不要尖叫。他说：“想到我们要熬过这一切，真不可思议。”我们的一大部分永远留在了那里。我会告诉你接下来发生了什么，你想知道的关于之后发生的一切。但此时此刻，我不能。正如当时一样，我在寻找我的女儿和那个消息之间的联系。
We arrived at the door of the hospital. Jean-Bernard asked where we had to go, and the porter replied, "In surgery." Then I thought that my daughters had been operated on before they died, and everything expanded into infinity again. Corridors. It was difficult to walk. My sister-in-law at the end of the corridor, arms circling around her, a room. My brother-in-law, my sister-in-law, a stranger. They ask us if we would like to see them, if we wanted to see our daughters. You would have had to drag me there with a tractor.
我们到达了医院门口。让-伯纳德问我们该去哪里，门卫回答说：“在手术室。”当时我以为我的女儿们在死前接受了手术，一切又扩大到了无限。走廊。走得很艰难。嫂子在走廊尽头，双臂环抱自己，一个房间。我的妹夫，我的嫂子，一个陌生人。他们问我们是否想见她们，是否想见我们的女儿。你得用拖拉机才能把我拖过去。
They ask us if we would like to ring anyone to let them know. I then understand that this horror does not stop at us, that we have to tell my mother. No, it's the evening. She's not expecting any news this evening. Let her sleep one more time.
他们问我们是否想给谁打电话告知情况。我随即明白，这种恐怖并没有止于我们，我们必须告诉我的母亲。不，现在是晚上。她今晚没期待任何消息。让她再睡个好觉吧。
I was right. They need the family record book. When they ask for it, and I reply, "Yes, we've brought it with us," I feel proud for a moment. We are good parents. We thought of everything. Aline and Christian are going to spend the night in the hospital near their baby Aude. All three are kept under observation.
我是对的。他们需要家庭户口本。当他们要求看时，我回答说：“是的，我们带来了。”那一刻我感到自豪。我们是好父母。我们想到了一切。艾琳和克里斯蒂安将在医院里，守在她们的婴儿奥德身边过夜。他们三个都被留下来观察。
We are taken back. In fact, we came for nothing. Right from the first instant, death is this nothing. Mrs. L suggests that we stay the night at her house. I agree readily. She lost a son long ago. At the L's house, we eat what we are given, food and sleeping pills.
我们被带回来了。事实上，我们白跑了一趟。从那一瞬间起，死亡就是这种虚无。L夫人建议我们在她家过夜。我欣然同意。她很久以前失去了一个儿子。在L夫人家，我们吃了给我们的东西，食物和安眠药。
It is not so much in words that I'm lacking to tell you all this but in courage. When I realize that I have forgotten something, and I have to retrace my steps, I say to myself: "Is it really worth it?"
告诉我这一切，我所缺少的不是词汇，而是勇气。当我意识到我忘记了什么，必须回溯我的脚步时，我对自己说：“真的值得吗？”
Before taking the sleeping pill, we thought that over at La Haye, their grandparents were waiting for our daughters. Laurent's parents. Have I told you that they were attending the coronation of Queen Beatrix of Holland? Have I told you that on the 30th of April 1980, this young woman was rising to the throne, and that, ever since, this date has been celebrated there as a joyful anniversary of an event whose secondary effect was the death of the girls? That my father-in-law, the French ambassador, and my mother-in-law were attending the festivities? That all the embassy staff were busy so we had found no one to go and fetch the girls at the airport? That, resigned only at the very last minute, I had canceled the places reserved for them on the Air France flight?
在服用安眠药之前，我们想到在拉埃，她们的祖父母正在等待我们的女儿。劳伦特的父母。我告诉过你他们正在参加荷兰贝娅特丽克丝女王的加冕典礼吗？我告诉过你1980年4月30日，这位年轻女性登上了王位，从那时起，这个日期就被视为一个欢乐事件的周年纪念日，而其附带效应是女孩们的死亡吗？我那身为法国大使的岳父和岳母正在参加庆祝活动吗？所有使馆工作人员都在忙碌，所以我们没找到人去机场接女孩们？我只在最后一刻才不得不取消了为她们预订的法国航空机票吗？
Have I told you that at my mother's house, before they were picked up by their aunt, they had watched the coronation ceremony on television, as I had done out of the corner of my eye at home? Have I told you that seeing my father-in-law's very characteristic form and gait, I telephoned my mother to ask whether everyone had spotted him, and I can still hear in the background Mathilde's voice full of disappointment: "No, I didn't see him." The very, very last time. My mother told me that at the time Elise was turned away from the television, absorbed in her drawing, but that that had not stopped her from affirming energetically, "But I did. I saw him!"
我告诉过你，在我母亲家，在被她们的阿姨接走之前，她们在电视上看了加冕典礼，就像我在家里眼角余光瞥见的一样吗？我告诉过你，看到我岳父非常有特点的身形和步态，我打电话给我母亲问大家是否认出了他，而我仍然能在背景中听到马蒂尔德充满失望的声音：“不，我没看见他。”那真的是最后一次。我母亲告诉我，当时埃莉斯背对着电视，沉浸在画画中，但这并没有阻止她充满活力地肯定：“但我看见了！我看见他了！”
Since then I have not called Mathilde nor Elise. Or if I have called my eldest daughter, it was without the hope that she would reply. It was to feel the vibration in my larynx of those syllables chosen when I was 25 years old, the arrangement of clear vowels and aquatic consonants, which were to name the first of my children to accompany her all her life, to act as her passport, announce her arrival, to be said with only a hint of shyness, and finally-- in the mouth of the one who would love her-- to betray all the emotions that this girl would one day elicit, that she alone would arouse in one young man, a young man who will never know her, who lives and who does not live to love her.
从那时起，我没有再叫过马蒂尔德或埃莉斯。或者如果我叫了我大女儿的名字，那也是没有任何她会回应的希望。那是为了感受我25岁时选择的那些音节在喉咙里的振动，那些清晰的元音和灵动辅音的排列，它们是为了命名我的第一个孩子，陪伴她一生，充当她的护照，宣告她的到来，带着一丝羞涩说出，最后——在那个爱她的人口中——背叛了所有这个女孩有朝一日会激起的感情，只有她一个人能在一个年轻男人心中唤起，一个永远不会认识她、活着却不再为爱她而活的年轻男人的心中。
After the funeral, I went over to my mother to see my aunt and uncle who would soon be returning to Haute Savoie. The concierge came out of her lodge to see me as I went into the building. Mathilde often used to go over to play with her daughter. She said, "You will see. You can get used to anything." It is certainly the most simple, true, brutal, and perceptive thing that anyone said to me at the time. You could interpret it either as a message of hope or of crushing contempt for human nature.
葬礼后，我去看我母亲，见到了很快就要返回上萨瓦省的叔叔阿姨。当我走进大楼时，门房从她的小屋里出来看我。马蒂尔德过去常去找她女儿玩。她说：“你会看到的。你可以习惯任何事。”这无疑是我当时听到的最简单、真实、残酷且富有洞察力的话。你可以将其解读为希望的信息，或者对人性的毁灭性蔑视。
It is very strange this double rhythm that I have with you. I write to you, forcing myself to clarify a period of my life that I've done everything I can to understand but which has always been out of my grasp. It is said that reality outstrips fiction, but this is something else. The reality remains inaccessible.
这种我和你之间的双重节奏非常奇怪。我写信给你，强迫自己理清我生命中一段我尽力去理解但始终无法掌握的时期。俗话说现实超越虚构，但这又是另一回事。现实仍然遥不可及。
Since the death of the girls, 12 years and 16 days' time, I have honestly and constantly tried to unveil this reality without success. Perhaps I've already told you, sometimes I believe in them alive, my darling children, my darling little girls. These words, which are so light and yet so burdensome, cut through me then. And sometimes I believe in their death, on the edge of the motorway, 10 or so meters from each other, their legs in dungarees, their arms and heads on the side of the motorway. There's never a link between the two.
自从女孩们去世，12年16天的时间里，我真诚且持续地试图揭开这个现实，但未获成功。也许我已经告诉过你了，有时我相信她们还活着，我亲爱的孩子们，我亲爱的女儿们。这些如此轻盈却又如此沉重的词语，在那时刺痛了我。有时我相信她们的死亡，在高速公路的边缘，距离彼此大约10米的地方，她们穿着工装裤的双腿，她们的手臂和头在高速公路的边上。这两者之间永远没有联系。
The other rhythm constitutes the things I do in my current life, as if nothing had happened. Conversations, laughter, mutual friends, a double rhythm like a double life. You do not know whether they struggle against each other or enrich each other.
另一种节奏构成了我当前生活中的事情，仿佛什么都没发生过。交谈、笑声、共同的朋友，一种双重节奏就像一种双重生活。你不知道它们是在相互对抗还是相互丰富。
Have I already mentioned Yasser Arafat to you? This is what made me think of him. When Elise was born, I found myself battling with a huge, hungry baby. The few odd ounces of milk that I was able to supply in the first 24 hours of her life in hospital were definitely not enough for her, and she screamed constantly. With Mathilde crying on the telephone because she felt lost without me, I quickly lost my patience. I found myself brutally grasping Elise's cradle, which was on casters, and furiously pushing it away from my bed so that it was in danger of banging into the far wall. A second of silence, and then the crying started up again.
我提到过亚西尔·阿拉法特吗？这就是让我想到他的原因。埃莉斯出生时，我发现自己正在和一个巨大的、饥饿的婴儿作斗争。我在医院最初24小时内能提供的极少量牛奶显然不够她喝的，她一直在尖叫。随着马蒂尔德在电话里哭泣，因为她觉得没有我而迷失了，我很快失去了耐心。我粗暴地抓住装有轮子的埃莉斯的摇篮，愤怒地把它推离我的床，以至于它差点撞上远处的墙壁。一秒钟的沉默，然后哭声又开始了。
On the third day, my mother came to see me. She sat at the end of the bed and chatted. We were cheerful. We, the adults, were talking to each other, but I was looking at my daughter, who was looking back at me. Drawn by her gaze, I leaned over her and rubbed my nose on hers. She said, "Huh, huh." I stared at my mother to reassure myself that I had not dreamed it. It had quite knocked  the breath out of her. I did the same thing again, and Elise replied again. Third attempt, third exchange. And that was it. She was my child, my treasure, my stupefaction.
第三天，我母亲来看我。她坐在床脚聊天。我们很愉快。我们这些成年人在交谈，但我看着我的女儿，她也看着我。被她的目光所吸引，我俯身过去，用我的鼻子蹭了蹭她的鼻子。她说：“嗯，嗯。”我盯着我母亲，以确认自己没有做梦。这让她相当喘不过气来。我再次做了同样的动作，埃莉斯又回应了。第三次尝试，第三次交流。就是这样。她是我的孩子，我的珍宝，我的震惊。
For logistical reasons, it was my mother who came with Mathilde to pick me up from the hospital. I went down one of the big staircases. At the end of one of the ground floor corridors, I saw Mathilde in her little green Loden coat. She was watching silently, motionless, her nose pointing up another staircase. My mother pointed me out to her, and Mathilde started to walk towards me slowly. I handed Elise to my mother so that I could lift Mathilde into her rightful place in my arms. I can still feel to the nearest ounce the pressure of her legs around my waist.
由于后勤原因，是我母亲带着马蒂尔德来医院接我。我走下楼梯之一。在底楼走廊的尽头，我看到了马蒂尔德穿着她那件绿色洛登外套。她静静地站着，一动不动，鼻子指向另一段楼梯。我母亲把我的方向指给她看，马蒂尔德开始慢慢向我走来。我把埃莉斯交给母亲，以便把马蒂尔德抱进我怀里应有的位置。我至今仍能感受到她双腿紧扣我腰间那精确到盎司的压力。
She did not say anything, but she slowly and silently felt my face with their hands like a blind girl. During this rediscovery, this tender and cautious reunion, my mother was smiling and whispering sweet nothings to Elise. She had brown hair, olive skin, and huge eyes ringed with black coal and, to confront the October weather, she was wearing a woolen hat which was a bit too big for her, which skewed sideways over her ear. "She could be Yasser Arafat's daughter," my mother laughed.
她什么也没说，但她静静地用手像盲女一样摸索我的脸。在这个重新发现、这个温柔而谨慎的重逢过程中，我母亲微笑着，对埃莉斯低语着甜言蜜语。她留着棕色头发，橄榄色的皮肤，大大的眼睛周围环绕着黑色的煤渣，为了应对十月的天气，她戴着一顶对她来说有点太大的羊毛帽，歪歪斜斜地盖在耳朵上。“她可能是亚西尔·阿拉法特的女儿，”我母亲笑着说。
The other day, the radio announced that Yasser Arafat's plane had disappeared in a sandstorm in the Libyan desert. A few hours later, although the members of his entourage were killed or injured, he himself was found alive and grinning. Every time that a tragic event affects him but spares him-- the murder of an adviser, all sorts of attempts on his life, or an airplane crash-- I feel that hug again. When I think of the life he leads and the life that Elise led, when I think of the life expectancy they each had on that October day when my mother teased me about my daughter, to think that she is dead, and he is here.
前几天，广播宣布亚西尔·阿拉法特的飞机在利比亚沙漠的沙尘暴中失踪了。几个小时后，虽然他的随从人员有死有伤，但他本人却被发现活着，满脸笑容。每当悲剧影响了他却放过了他——顾问的谋杀、各种暗杀企图或飞机失事——我就又感到了那种拥抱。当我想到他过的生活和埃莉斯过的生活，当我想到我母亲逗我女儿的那天十月她们各自的预期寿命时，想到她去世了，而他在这里。
I've been careful. I've never watched the home movies in which my two daughters appear nor have I listened to their voices on the answering machine tapes that my mother kept. The messages to Granny are at her house, accessible, but I do nothing about it. How many catastrophes have there been since I began this correspondence with you? Football stadiums collapse. Young motor bikers kill each other at the 24-hour race in Le Mans. And here I am with the children and you. And I tug at my net, which has plunged so deep in water.
我很小心。我从未看过两个女儿出现的家庭录影带，也没有听过我母亲保留的答录机上的声音。给外婆的信息在她的房子里，可以访问，但我什么也没做。自从我开始与你通信以来，发生了多少次灾难？足球场倒塌了。年轻摩托车手在勒芒24小时耐力赛中丧生。而我在这里，带着孩子们和你们。我拉扯着我的网，它已经深深地沉入水中。
Last week, I spent a long time looking at a car exactly like the one in which my daughters fell asleep, from which they were thrown, in which, leaving their parents to go to their grandparents, they left Paris, never to return. I was there looking at the back seat, the seat belts that we had not done up, the right-hand window out of which they would have both been thrown.
上周，我花了很多时间看一辆车，和我的女儿们在其中睡着的那辆一模一样，她们从车里被甩出，她们离开父母去祖父母那里，离开巴黎，再也没有回来。我就站在那里看着后座，我们没有系上的安全带，右侧的车窗，她们俩就是从那里被甩出来的。
The letters on the number plate confirmed that this Renault 5 was from the same year as my sister-in-law's. They're still on the road, those cars. When there are none left, I will no longer be able to ask questions of them. Someone will have to keep one somewhere for me.
车牌上的字母证实这辆雷诺5和嫂子的是同一年份的。那些车还在路上跑呢。当一辆都不剩时，我就无法再向它们询问问题了。有人得为我留下一辆在某处。
After the impact when my sister-in-law managed to bring her car to a halt, she and her husband turned with relief to smile at the children. But only their baby was there, sitting in her little seat, stupefied, with some fragments of glass spread over her. Have I already told you that? I tell it to myself so many times. When I was near that Renault 5 the other day, I wanted to lie down on the rear seat and wait for the end of time. In short, back to square one.
撞击后，嫂子成功让车停下来，她和丈夫转过头，如释重负地微笑着看孩子们。但只有婴儿在，坐在她的小座椅上，惊呆了，身上撒着一些玻璃碎片。我告诉过你吗？我告诉自己很多次了。前几天我在那辆雷诺5附近时，我想躺在后座上，等待时间的终结。简而言之，回到原点。
I have some work to hand in, a lot, but nothing will get done until I've written to you. At first it was the other way around. Everything came before writing these letters. I used to tell myself, why suffer? What's the point of this artificial rendezvous with these long-lost children? I always had something happier to do. Now, even as I get up, I am carried by the things I want to write to you.
我有工作要做，很多，但在写信给你之前，什么都做不成。起初情况恰恰相反。一切都排在写这些信之前。我曾经对自己说，为什么要受苦？这些与失散已久的孩子们进行的人为会面有什么意义？我总是有更快乐的事情要做。现在，即使起床，我也被我想写给你的东西所承载。
I should have gone to see in that room in the hospital where they put my daughters. I knew as soon as they suggested it to me. I knew that by refusing, I was setting a precedent for a future of weakness because I was not worthy of-- I do not know what. Just not worthy. So I did not go to see them dead. They were there, and Mummy did not come. They were only one or two rooms away. They remained alone. Mummy did not cross the doorway.
我本应该去医院里那个放着我女儿们的房间看看。他们向我建议时我就知道了。我知道拒绝了，就是为未来树立了软弱的先例，因为我不配……我不知道什么。就是不配。所以我没去见她们的尸体。她们就在那里，而妈妈没有去。她们只隔着一两间房。她们依然孤独。妈妈没有跨过那个门口。
I know nothing of their faces as they were at the end. They had the strength to die, and I could not match their strength. I know nothing of their last great achievement. Wherever they went, they went alone, together or apart. And I'm inclined to believe it was apart. Ignorant of their own heroism, they went to the places dictated by their violent trajectory at more than 100 kilometers per hour over the safety barrier.
我不知道她们临终时的面容。她们有死亡的勇气，而我无法与她们的勇气相匹配。我对她们最后的伟大壮举一无所知。无论她们去了哪里，她们都是孤独地去的，一起或分开。我倾向于相信是分开。她们对自己英雄般的行为一无所知，在暴力轨迹的支配下，以每小时100多公里的速度越过安全护栏，去了那些地方。
I stayed on my chair like a lump. And since then, people have not stopped congratulating me for my courage as a mother. To such an extent that many friends, including you, hesitated before talking to us about the difficulties and hardships they were facing, they did not seem worthy in comparison. Laurent and I sat enthroned on a pedestal, hoisted there by the annihilation of our two little girls. But we still knew what real life was, like a weather map of constantly changing skies, and we needed people to tell us about it, because the air was thin for our two statues.
我像个肿块一样坐在椅子上。从那以后，人们就不断地赞美我作为母亲的勇气。以至于许多朋友，包括你，在谈论他们面临的困难和艰辛时犹豫不决，因为相比之下，他们觉得自己不配。劳伦特和我坐在基座上，被我们两个小女儿的毁灭所抬高。但我们仍然知道什么是真实的生活，就像天气图上不断变化的天空，我们需要人们告诉我们这些，因为对于我们这两座雕像来说，空气太稀薄了。
The only stance that I battle against is to threaten suicide, to keep those around you on tenterhooks because you claim you're going to die. Watch out, I'm going to kill myself. My goodness, the living can make a fuss with their moods and their other half running all over the place trying to stop them. I'm going to kill myself. Watch out! Watch out! Oh no, that is not how you do it.
我唯一反对的立场是威胁自杀，让周围的人一直处于紧张状态，因为你声称你要死了。小心，我要自杀了。天哪，活着的人可以因他们的情绪而大惊小怪，他们的另一半为了阻止他们而四处奔波。我要自杀了。小心！小心！哦不，那不是你应该做的方式。
I will explain to these maniacs how Mathilde and Elise managed to die. If I can, that is, because they did the whole thing by themselves. And when the adults came to their senses and began to realize that they were no longer in the car, not even under the front seats where they looked once they realized the rear seat was empty, when they had to resign themselves to getting out of the car to look for them, they had to be found wherever they might be. When it was done and they had been found dozens of meters from the car and dozens of meters apart, they had actually already gone without a word to a place that no man can see.
我会向这些疯子解释马蒂尔德和埃莉斯是如何死去的。如果我能的话，因为她们是自己完成这一切的。当大人们回过神来，开始意识到她们不在车里，甚至不在他们发现后座是空的之后看过的座位下面，当他们不得不强迫自己走出车外去寻找她们时，她们必须在她们可能在的任何地方被找到。当一切完成，她们在距离车子几十米远、彼此相距几十米的地方被发现时，她们实际上已经一声不响地去了一个人类无法看见的地方。
All of this brings me back to that moment of weakness on my chair when even though two children, my two children, two very young children, had known how to die and were waiting to be presented to me one last time in their truthfulness, I had not even gone those few meters along the corridor that separated them from me. They had known how to die. I no longer knew how to walk.
所有这些都让我回到了坐在椅子上的那一刻软弱无力的时候，即使两个孩子，我的两个孩子，两个非常年幼的孩子，已经知道如何死亡，并等待着在她们的真实中最后一次展示给我看，我甚至没有走过那条分隔她们和我的走廊上的几米距离。她们知道如何死去。我却不再知道如何行走。
There has been nothing glorious about the way I live my life. I love the living in all their miasma. I love the dead for their temerity. There is nothing in between.
我生活的道路没有什么光荣之处。我爱所有困惑中的活人。我爱死人的鲁莽。中间什么也没有。
Our children now, Elvire and Gauthier, have asked us 100 times whether they would have been born if their sisters had not died. I really hope so, but I just cannot say. The girls' death allowed me to be pregnant again, which I wanted anyway, to have other children, which I wanted anyway.
我们的孩子们现在，埃尔薇尔和高蒂尔，问了我们100次，如果她们的姐姐没有去世，她们还会出生吗。我真的希望如此，但我无法说。女孩们的死亡让我能够再次怀孕，这也是我想要的，拥有其他的孩子，这也是我想要的。
Even so, at the square with the children, I was not like other mothers. Sitting on the bench or on the side of the sand pit, I would watch my Elvire making mud pies, and I would let Gauthier suck on his biscuit. If another woman wanted to talk to me, I had only two options. A bright facade, which devastated me-- yes, mine's already three and a half, but she's still frightened of the slide. I can't believe your little scrap. He's so brave up at the top of the ladder-- or a truth that was socially unacceptable. These are my younger two children. The elder ones died four years ago.
即便如此，在广场和孩子们在一起时，我还是不像其他的母亲。坐在长椅上或沙坑边，我会看着埃尔薇尔做泥饼，我会让高蒂尔吸吮他的饼干。如果有另一位女性想和我说话，我只有两个选择。一个明亮的门面，这摧毁了我——是的，我的已经三岁半了，但她还是怕滑梯。真不敢相信你那小个子。他在梯子顶上真勇敢——或者一个在社交上不可接受的事实。这是我的两个小孩子。大的四个前去世了。
I would always be out of place. The working class, immigrants, the self-taught cranks, the handicapped, the unemployed, and grieving parents are more alike than people think. They have at least one thing in common. They have to make Herculean efforts to hold a normal, banal, bouncy conversation. They can think of only one thing, the moment when they might introduce a sentence about their misfortune. Thirteen years have passed, and I still cannot last half a day without evoking my daughters.
我总是格格不入。工人阶级、移民、自学的怪人、残疾人、失业者和悲伤的父母比人们想象的更相似。他们至少有一个共同点。他们必须付出巨大的努力才能进行正常的、平庸的、充满活力的交谈。他们只能想到一件事，那个他们可能引入一句关于不幸的句子的时刻。十三年过去了，我还是不能在半天内不提起我的女儿。
Elvire has received a post card from a friend announcing the death of a classmate. I was having a siesta. In my drowsy state, I could hear the voice of my 12-year-old daughter talking to her father, respecting her mother's sleep. "I'm going to have to tell Gauthier, aren't I?" He was playing with his cousin. Gauthier does not want to hear about anything to do with death, so when Elvire told him, he hid his feelings and hardly broke off from his game. And Elvire was left alone with this news, which she had just learned from one of those holiday cards that should never give you that sort of news.
埃尔薇尔收到了一张朋友的明信片，宣布了一名同学的死讯。我正在午睡。在昏昏欲睡的状态下，我可以听到我12岁女儿的声音在对她父亲说话，尊重她母亲的睡眠。“我得告诉高蒂尔，对吧？”他正和表兄弟玩耍。高蒂尔不想听任何关于死亡的消息，所以当埃尔薇尔告诉他时，他隐藏了自己的感受，几乎没有中断他的游戏。埃尔薇尔独自一人留在这个消息中，这是她刚刚从那些本不应该给你这种消息的节日卡片之一中得知的。
"What's going on?" I asked, pretending to have heard nothing and feeling sure that Elvire would want to tell me everything herself. She joined me on the bed, buried herself against me, sighed, and then cried. She had been telling me about this friend's illness since the beginning of the school year. I knew that Lauren came to school sporadically, that she had changed physically, that her mother, who was always cheerful, came to pick her up from school with her two younger children, asking her whether she had forgotten anything in her locker, as you would to a child who still has 10 or 15 years of school ahead of them. Then that was it. Lauren sank into a coma.
“发生什么事了？”我问，假装什么都没听到，并确信埃尔薇尔会想自己把一切都告诉我。她来到床上，埋在我的怀里，叹了口气，然后哭了。自从开学以来，她一直告诉我这个朋友的病情。我知道劳伦断断续续地来学校，她的身体发生了变化，她总是很开朗的母亲带着她的两个小孩子来学校接她，问她是否忘记在储物柜里留下什么，就像对待一个还有10或15年学校生活要走的孩子一样。然后就是这样。劳伦陷入了昏迷。
Elvire had told me about that, too, but now, as she cried, she realized she had never imagined that Lauren would actually die. And this death, this end to everything, this earthly truth, which meant that the child, who had been told not to forget anything in her locker would not begin the next academic year in three weeks' time. This was so harsh and so invincible that Elvire had only her tears to link the two realities, that of a life yesterday, which was complete even in a state of coma, and death, which was eternal right from the first moment.
埃尔薇尔也告诉过我这件事，但现在，当她哭泣时，她意识到她从未想象过劳伦真的会死。这种死亡，这种一切的终结，这种世俗的真相，意味着那个被告知不要在储物柜里留下任何东西的孩子，不会在三周后开始下一个学年。这是如此严酷和无坚不摧，以至于埃尔薇尔只能用她的泪水来连接这两个现实，一个是昨天的生活，即使在昏迷状态下也是完整的，另一个是死亡，从第一刻起就是永恒的。
Now, even as she struggled with the sharp pain, she already knew that soon, very soon, this pain would soften. And despite her sobs, her shuddering little frame, her puffy red face, she was already missing the purity of this revolt before it had even begun to fade. And she refused to accept that this sorrow would become integrated into her life. "When I tell my children about this one day, they won't understand how horrible it was," she told me. "And then, maybe even tomorrow, there will already be moments when I don't think about it."
现在，即使她在剧痛中挣扎，她也已经知道，很快，非常快，这种痛苦就会软弱下来。尽管她抽泣，她颤抖的小身躯，她红肿的脸，她已经开始怀念这种反抗的纯洁，在它甚至还没有开始褪色之前。她拒绝接受这种悲伤会融入她的生活。“当我有一天告诉我的孩子们这件事时，他们不会理解它是多么可怕，”她告诉我。“然后，也许甚至明天，就会有我不去想它的时刻。”
This idea redoubled her anger. Far from hoping to suffer less, she never wanted the freshness of the pain to deaden. This was the only acceptable response to a disappearance that every part of her refused to accept. As I listened to her, I loved her for having already understood everything. And I thought of these letters in which so many years later, I try to discover exactly what has become of all those feelings.
这个想法加倍了她的愤怒。远非希望少受苦，她从不希望痛苦的新鲜感被消磨。对于消失来说，这是唯一可以接受的回应，她身体的每一部分都拒绝接受。听着她说话，我爱她，因为她已经理解了一切。我想到了这些信件，在多年后的今天，我试图弄清楚所有这些感受究竟变成了什么。
Genevieve Jurgensen's is book is called The Disappearance. It's published by Norton. Excerpts were read for our show by actress Felicity Jones.
吉纳维芙·尤根森的书叫《消失》。由诺顿出版。摘录由女演员费莉西蒂·琼斯为我们的节目朗读。
Coming up, death takes a holiday, and while it's gone, can you feel better about tragedy by talking about it in advance? And if not, what's talking for anyway? That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，死亡度假，当它离开时，你可以通过提前谈论悲剧来感觉更好吗？如果不行，谈论又是为了什么？来自公共广播国际的节目继续，一分钟后揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different stories on that theme. Today's program, telling stories in the face of death.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会在节目中选择一个主题，并为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是：面对死亡讲述故事。
In each of our acts today, somebody contemplates the death of a person that he or she is close to and then surrounds that idea of that death with words and stories, even though to some degree, in that situation, words and stories cannot entirely do what we normally want them to do, which is to comfort us, to give order.
在今天节目的每一幕中，有人凝视着他或她亲近之人的死亡，然后用言语和故事包围那个死亡的概念，尽管在某种程度上，在这种情况下，言语和故事无法完全做到我们通常希望它们做到的事情，也就是安慰我们，给予秩序。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Look for the Union Label. In this act, two people, father and daughter-- we'll hear from them both-- start to compose a story about death before anyone has died.
我们到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，《寻找工会标签》。在这一幕中，两个人，父亲和女儿——我们将听到他们俩的声音——在任何人去世之前就开始编织关于死亡的故事。
Well, it simply began by sitting in the kitchen of my home, reading the Boston Globe, and I looked out on a beautiful fall day, looking out at a maple tree in front of my yard. And suddenly, it occurred to me that I should write my obituary. I'll begin working on it. No special reason.
嗯，这只是从坐在我家的厨房里，读着《波士顿环球报》开始的，我向外望着一个美丽的秋日，看着我院子前面的一棵枫树。突然，我想到我应该写我的讣告。我开始动手。没有特别的原因。
It must've been probably over the Christmas holidays, probably last year.
那肯定是在圣诞假期期间，可能是去年。
And you were visiting your parents' house?
你在拜访你父母的房子？
My parents.
我的父母。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
Around that time, and I was on the telephone, and I was just looking for a pad of paper to write something down. And I just noticed on a yellow legal pad that my father had started writing his obituary.
就在那时候，我在打电话，我只是在找个纸垫写点东西。我刚好注意到我父亲在一个黄色法律垫纸上开始写他的讣告。
But it wasn't labeled obituary at the time.
但当时并没有标注是讣告。
No. No. It said born in 1917 to-- Albany, and it just was incredibly straightforward and standard. And I just couldn't believe it. I didn't actually have an emotional response to the obituary part at all. I was just sort of-- I guess I was amused in a way, because he is such an interesting person, and the writing, it was just the most basic details about his family, and it didn't really say anything about him.
不。不。它说出生于1917年……阿尔巴尼，而且非常直接和标准。我简直不敢相信。我实际上对讣告的部分一点也没有情感反应。我只是觉得……我想我有点被逗乐了，因为他是一个如此有趣的人，而写作内容，只是关于他家庭的最基本细节，并没有真正说明关于他的任何事情。
In other words, he's a more interesting person than the writing itself.
换句话说，他是一个比文字本身更有趣的人。
Right. I don't know. And I didn't really process the thought. I just went straight to him, and I said, Dad, my God, this is so boring. I said you've lived a much more interesting life than this. And he said, well, then help me write it. You're a writer. Help me write it. And all he knew was what the headline should be. That was the one very clear thing that he knew.
对。我不知道。我没有真正处理这个想法。我直接走到他面前说：爸爸，天哪，这太无聊了。我说你过的一生比这有趣得多。他说，那帮我写。你是作家。帮我写。他唯一知道的就是标题应该是什么。那是他清楚知道的一件事。
And what should the headline be?
那标题应该是什么？
The headline should be his name. I'm named after him, and it should say Adrian LeBlank comma product of the working class. That was what he saw.
标题应该是他的名字。我以他的名字命名，它应该写：艾德里安·勒布朗，逗号，工人阶级的产物。这就是他看到的。
Well, to me, that's really important. Because when I say the working class, I'm talking about workers, you know?
嗯，对我来说，这非常重要。因为当我谈论工人阶级时，我在谈论工人，你知道吗？
Yeah.
嗯。
Throughout my history, from the first factory job, first learning what a union was, and then being a committee man and president of the local unions wherever I worked, and from then on, I gravitate to becoming a full-time field representative. I tend to take positions, you know? I do this every day of my life, and I think that the obituary is like saying there are still union guys around. You follow?
贯穿我的历史，从第一份工厂工作，第一次了解什么是工会，然后成为委员会成员和无论我在哪里工作的地方工会主席，从那以后，我倾向于成为一名全职现场代表。我倾向于表明立场，你知道吗？我每天都这么做，我认为讣告就像是说，仍然有工会成员存在。你明白吗？
Yeah.
嗯。
I don't know if that's clear. But that was pretty much it. It's like saying, you know, look, 82 years later, from 16 to 82, there are still guys who are making a pitch.
我不知道这是否清楚。但差不多就是这样。就像是说，你知道，看，82年后，从16岁到82岁，依然有家伙在努力。
And so we sit down. I'm pretty sure that first day we sat down, I opened my portable computer, and I said OK. And he said so how do we do this? What  do we do? And I said, well, I just need you to tell me about your life.
我们就坐下来。我很确定第一天我们坐下来时，我打开了便携式电脑，我说“好的”。他说“那我们怎么做？我们该做什么？”我说，嗯，我只需要你告诉我你的生活。
I've actually tried to do this with my dad before, not in the context of the obituary, but in those moments where I felt that I need to learn about my family history. But he was not very responsive. He would be very vague. But for some reason, when he was thinking of his life in terms of an obituary, a lot of details came out that I don't feel I could've-- well, I wasn't able to get when I was trying to just have straight conversations with him about his biography, daughter to father.
其实我以前就试过和爸爸这样做，不是在讣告的背景下，而是在那些我觉得需要了解家族史的时刻。但他反应不强烈。他会非常含糊。但出于某种原因，当他从讣告的角度思考他的人生时，很多细节就涌现出来了，我觉得我没法……嗯，当我试图以女儿对父亲的身份和他进行直接的传记谈话时，我无法获得这些细节。
I was wondering if it was an enjoyable process for you talking to your daughter?
我很好奇这对你来说是否是一个愉快的与女儿交谈的过程？
Yes, yes, yes. I find her to be a searcher and a prober and with good instincts and caring.
是的，是的，是的。我发现她是一个探索者，一个钻研者，有着很好的本能，并且充满关怀。
So I don't know. It was just interesting, and it came very easily. I learned so much about him.
所以我不知道。这很有趣，而且来得非常容易。我了解到了很多关于他的事。
Since it was an obituary you were writing, did the two of you talk about his death?
既然你们写的是讣告，你们俩谈过他的死亡吗？
No. That's something that I think is-- I don't know. It's funny. In preparing for this, several of my friends were asking me about it, and it just shocked me a little bit that they were thinking about it in that way. And then, of course, I realized it is an obituary.
不。那是我认为……我不知道。很有趣。在为这个做准备时，我的几个朋友问我这个问题，他们以那种方式思考，这让我感到有点震惊。然后，当然，我意识到这确实是一份讣告。
I wonder if he understands it more the other way, that as far as he's concerned, it really is about his death?
我想知道他是否更从另一个角度理解这一点，即对他而言，这确实是关于他的死亡？
I think he must, and I think over the years, he's known how anxious my brother and I have been about him dying. So I think he often tries in his way to help us cope with it. He doesn't seem nervous or frightened, so I don't know. When I leave when I go to visit, I find leaving my parents sometimes quite difficult because they are older, and I'm very busy, and I don't get back as often as I'd like to. And I think he knows how hard it is for me to say goodbye. And he'll say I'm always with you, and I'll always be with you, that kind of thing.
我想他一定是这样理解的，而且我认为多年来，他知道我和我哥哥对他去世有多么焦虑。所以我认为他常常试着以他的方式帮助我们应对。他看起来并不紧张或害怕，所以我不知道。我离开去探望时，我发现离开父母有时相当困难，因为他们年纪大了，我非常忙，我没法像我想的那样经常回去。我想他知道我对告别感到多么困难。他会说我一直和你在一起，我会一直陪着你，诸如此类。
Yeah. I wonder  if this whole process, you think you're doing it for him in a way, but maybe it's for you.
嗯。我想知道整个过程，你以为你是为他做的，但也许它是为你做的。
Mm-hm.
嗯。
He's doing this all for you.
他做这一切都是为了你。
Right. I believe that's very possible. I think that's very possible, which is probably why he was a good union organizer. Because I'm feeling like I'm helping him do something. You know, he was good at what he did.
对。我相信这非常有可能是这样。我认为这非常有可能是这样，这可能就是为什么他是个好的工会组织者。因为我觉得我在帮他做某事。你知道，他在他做的事情上很擅长。
Is one of the reasons that you've agreed to talk to your daughter about the obituary and work with her on the obituary is to help her prepare for the thought that you might die?
你同意和女儿谈论讣告并与她合作，其中一个原因是帮助她为可能面临的死亡做好准备吗？
It could be. I haven't stayed with that thought, but it could very well be, Ira. Maybe you're cluing in. I think that thought has crossed my mind, but I haven't stayed with it.
可能是吧。我没在这个想法上停留，但很有可能，艾拉。也许你猜对了。我想那个想法曾经闪过我的脑海，但我没有停留在上面。
Hm.
嗯。
I haven't stayed, but you could be partially right.
我没停留，但你可能是对的。
Is there a way to ever-- I'm not sure I would want it to be easier, but I wonder if it's possible? Is it possible to even know what that could be like?
有没有一种方式能……我不确定我希望它更容易，但我很好奇这是否可能？有没有可能知道那会是什么样子？
You're saying that no matter how we try to prepare for the death of somebody so close to us, there really is nothing we can do. We can think about it all we want.
你是说无论我们如何试图为亲近之人的死亡做好准备，实际上我们什么也做不了。我们可以随心所欲地思考它。
Yeah, I definitely feel that with it. I mean, because obviously, I've been working on an obituary, not really thinking at all about my father dying, not thinking that it's about death, just thinking that it's about talking to my father, that I have all the time to sort of figure this out. I don't know. It's part of my relationship with him will be what happens when it's over, when he's physically gone.
是的，我绝对有那种感觉。我的意思是，因为很明显，我一直在写讣告，并没有真正想到我父亲去世的事，并不认为它是关于死亡的，只是认为这是关于和父亲交谈，我有所有时间来弄明白这一切。我不知道。这是我和他关系的一部分，当一切结束，当他物理上离去时会发生什么。
I mean, my brother-in-law passed away, and he was quite sick before he died, and he was in a coma right up to the moment that he actually did die. And there was such a vast difference between him-- even though he wasn't available as the person we'd known, his physical life was so immense. And when it was gone, it was-- the loss of it was just huge, you know? It was huge, and it happened in just a minute. And I just was so shocked by that because I was so ready for him to die. We knew that he was going to die. He wasn't really with us anymore, and it was just-- and I was glad that I was able to at least understand how little I actually knew about it.
我是说，我的姐夫去世了，他在去世前病得很重，直到他真正死亡的那一刻他都处于昏迷状态。即使他不再是我们所认识的那个人，他的生命依然极其巨大。当它消失时，那是……损失的规模是巨大的，你知道吗？这是巨大的，而且发生在一分钟之内。我被此深深震撼，因为我已经为他的死亡做好了准备。我们知道他会死。他不再真正和我们在一起了，这只是……我很高兴我至少能够理解我对此实际上是多么无知。
So how far are the two of you on the obit? Have you finished it?
那你们俩的讣告写到哪一步了？写完了吗？
No. No. I haven't actually-- I can't figure out how to write it except in the past tense, and it just seems completely bizarre to speak of him in that way.
没有。不。我实际上还没能……我无法弄清楚如何以过去式来写它，用那种方式谈论他显得完全怪异。
So I understand she hasn't finished writing it.
所以我了解她还没写完。
No, we haven't completed it, no.
没有，我们还没完成，不。
Do you feel like she's taking too long getting this done?
你觉得她写得太久了吗？
Do I think she's taking too long?
你觉得她花的时间太长了吗？
Yeah.
对。
No, I didn't feel there was any-- there's no great rush that I know of. Why? Do you have a feeling there should be a timetable?
没有，我不觉得有什么……据我所知没有特别急。为什么？你觉得应该有一个时间表吗？
No, I don't.
不，我没有。
Are you rushing the process, Ira?
你在催促这个过程吗，艾拉？
No. No, I have no intention to rush the process.
没有。不，我无意催促这个过程。
I'm not going anywhere. I'm still bowling on Fridays with the senior citizens.
我哪儿也不去。我星期五还在和老年人一起打保龄球。
Adrian LeBlank and his daughter, also named Adrian LeBlank.
艾德里安·勒布朗和他的女儿，也叫艾德里安·勒布朗。
[MUSIC - "OVER THE RAINBOW" BY JERRY LEE LEWIS]
[音乐 - 杰瑞·李·刘易斯的《彩虹之上》]
Act Three, Take My Wife, Please. Some of us have tragedy thrust upon us. Some of us creep up tentatively to the edge of thinking about our worst fears and only allow ourselves a few quick moments to contemplate them before burying all thought of tragedy deep into the backs of our minds again. And then, some of us choose to think about the worst that can happen-- all the time. And is that good for you? One of the producers of This American Life, Julie Snyder, has this story about her brother.
第三幕，《带上我的妻子，拜托》。我们中有些人遭遇了悲剧。有些人小心翼翼地走到思考最坏恐惧的边缘，只允许自己花一点时间来思考，然后就又把所有对悲剧的想法深深埋藏在脑海的深处。还有些人选择思考可能发生的最坏情况——一直思考。这对你有好处吗？《美国生活》的制片人之一，朱莉·斯奈德，有这个关于她哥哥的故事。
A little over a year ago, I was in the car with my older brother Tom, coming back from a weekend trip to our dad's house. And just as we were entering Chicago, he began to tell me about how whenever he says goodbye to someone or hangs up the phone at the end of a conversation, what goes through his head is that might be the last time he'll ever talk to them. And that's just the beginning.
一年多前，我和我哥哥汤姆在车里，从我们父亲家度完周末回来。就在我们进入芝加哥时，他开始告诉我，每当他跟某人说再见或结束谈话挂断电话时，脑子里闪过的就是那可能是他最后一次跟他们谈话。而那只是个开始。
Then I think about what would happen, what would I do, and what would be the reaction if that particular person died. For instance, who would take care of the funeral plans? Who would call the cops, I guess would be initially. Do I touch the body? Do I call the cops first? If there's foul play involved, do I like-- if I was in an apartment, like if it was my wife or something, should I investigate to see if anyone's still around or not? Would I freak out or would I able to handle seeing the sight of my particular wife or loved one dead or mutilated?
然后我想会发生什么，我会做什么，如果那个人去世了会有什么反应。比如，谁来照顾葬礼安排？谁来报警，我想最初会报警。我要触碰尸体吗？我是先报警吗？如果涉及谋杀，我要去调查是否还有人在现场吗？我会崩溃还是能处理看到我亲爱的妻子或爱人死亡或残缺的场景？
It's at this point that Tom notices the look of horror on my face.
就在这一点上，汤姆注意到了我脸上惊恐的表情。
What, what? What are you looking at me like that for?
什么，什么？你为什么那样看着我？
It's just crazy. I didn't know you had cops involved.
这太疯狂了。我不知道你还牵扯到警察。
Well, yeah, if you're the  first one who stumbles on the scene. There's no sense in talking about the funeral and your life thereafter if you can't deal with what happens right away.
嗯，是的，如果你是第一个碰巧在现场的人。如果你处理不了直接发生的事情，那谈论葬礼和你之后的生活就毫无意义了。
Tom has really specific plans for what he'll do when almost every member of our family dies. But his most detailed scenario is for his wife Lisa.
汤姆对我们家几乎每个人去世后他要做的事都有非常具体的计划。但他最详细的场景是关于他的妻子丽莎。
What am I going to do to get through the initial day? And what's going to happen to her body? Is it going to go to the coroner's office? Will there be an autopsy? Probably.
第一天我要怎么做才能熬过去？她的身体会发生什么？会去验尸官办公室吗？会有尸检吗？可能吧。
And what happens when I come home? Who will  I call? What will my words be to her parents when I have to explain to them that she's dead? And how am I going to tell them? Of course, where do I sleep? Do I come  home and sleep that night? How am I going to eat?
当我回家时会发生什么？我会给谁打电话？当我不得不向她父母解释她死了时，我要对他们说什么？我该怎么告诉他们？当然，我睡哪里？我那晚回家睡觉吗？我该怎么吃饭？
OK, am I going to go to work? Will I be able in the morning period of the first week to just carve out a couple hours and finish this up? Will I continue to work? Can I just take the time off? I have a lot of law school debt still. But then again, of course, my wife's life is insured through her job, and so I'd have that extra money. Would I continue to live in the house or not, I think. Now, she's pregnant, of course, and so that's going to turn-- that's another equation.
好的，我要去工作吗？在第一周的哀悼期里，我能抽出几个小时把事情处理完吗？我会继续工作吗？我可以请假吗？我还有很多法学院债务。但另一方面，当然，我妻子的生命通过她的工作有了保险，所以我会有那笔额外的钱。我想我会继续住在这所房子里还是不。现在，她怀孕了，所以那会转……那是另一个等式。
Do you have any idea how long you've kind of been doing this for?
你知道你这样想有多久了吗？
Let's see. I'm 32, so probably 10 years probably. Yeah, I don't know what started me thinking along the lines of people close to me dying, because nobody has, which is kind of peculiar that I would think this way. But maybe that's why I think this way, because it hasn't happened to me yet, and I'm just waiting for it to happen. But every time I come home and I see a message on the answering machine, particularly at night, I oftentimes think is this going to be the call with the bad news?
让我想想。我32岁，所以大概有10年了。是的，我不知道是什么让我开始思考身边亲近的人会死亡，因为没有人去世，我竟然会这样想，真是有点特别。但也许这就是我这样想的原因，因为这还没发生在我身上，我只是在等待它发生。但每次我回家看到答录机上有留言，特别是晚上，我经常会想，这会是那个坏消息的电话吗？
I just need to stop right here and say that my brother is much more normal than all of this makes him seem. He's really smart and funny and sweet. He's a successful attorney, married, and has his first baby on the way. It's just that he worries. A lot.
我只需要在这里停一下，说我哥哥比这一切让他看起来的要正常得多。他真的很聪明、幽默、贴心。他是一位成功的律师，已婚，第一个孩子即将出生。只是他担心。想得很多。
I think it's morbid. By definition, it's morbid. I'm thinking about people's morbidity or mortality. But I think it's practical, too. It makes you appreciate the person so much more. When you play the answering machine and it's just a telemarketer, and you're like, well, my mom must not be dead, because, of course, if that happened, I would get a phone call. It would be on my machine, and I don't have one. Ergo my mom, who I love, is still alive. So I think that I don't see any detriment to the way I think and even about things that aren't-- issues I'm not presented with in terms of people dying, because it gives me better appreciation, I think, for life.
我想这很病态。从定义上来说，这很病态。我在思考人们的病态或死亡率。但我认为这也很实用。它让你更珍惜那个人。当你播放答录机，那只是个电话推销员，你会想，好吧，我妈妈肯定没死，因为如果那样的话，我会接到电话的。它会出现在我的答录机上，而我没有收到。所以我想不出我这种思考方式有什么弊端，即使是关于我还没面临的问题，因为我认为这让我更欣赏生活。
Do you think this kind of emotionally keeps you closer to our family then?
你认为这种方式在情感上让你和我们家人更亲近了吗？
Yeah, I certainly do, without a doubt, both to my family and to my friends. The only emotions I ever feel when I'm thinking this way is kind of-- and I know you're going to think this is bizarre, is like kind of a satisfaction in knowing that I care so much and that so much-- if this person was to go, how much this person meant to me and how much they helped me in my life and just made my life better. It just gives me a little satisfaction knowing they're not dead.
是的，毫无疑问，既对我的家人也对我的朋友。当我这样思考时，我感受到的唯一情绪有点——我知道你会觉得这很奇怪——就是一种满足感，因为我知道我非常在乎，如果这个人离开了，这个人对我意味着什么，他们在生活中给了我多少帮助，让我的生活变得更好。知道他们还没死，这给了我一点满足感。
And I've thought oftentimes about delivering eulogies at people's funerals, my mother's, my grandparents. So I've thought about all the good things I would say. My dad's funeral, too. The things I would say to celebrate their lives and say what they meant to me.
而且我经常想在人们的葬礼上致悼词，我母亲的、我祖父母的。所以我已经考虑过我会说的所有好话。我父亲的葬礼也是。那些我会说出来庆祝他们生命的话，以及他们对我意味着什么的话。
I asked if he had a eulogy for me. He says it's pretty much the same speech he gave at my wedding.
我问他是否也为我准备了悼词。他说这和他婚礼上致辞的演讲差不多。
I wouldn't characterize it maybe as a rush or a cheap thrill so much as it's just something that you know is going to happen. You're going to die. Martin's going to die. Gina's going die. My wife's going to die. My mom's going to die. I'm not going to be around probably to see all that happen, but certainly, some of them I probably will be. And so I think that in the final analysis, I think there's nothing wrong with thinking this way, and I think it's healthy.
我不会将其描述为一种急切或廉价的快感，更多的是一种你知道会发生的事情。你会死。马丁会死。吉娜会死。我的妻子会死。我妈妈会死。我可能无法在身边见证这一切，但当然，其中一些我可能会见证。所以我认为归根结底，我认为这样想没什么不对，我觉得这很健康。
I know my wife disagrees with me. I know she thinks that if I were to tell anybody, which now I am, that I think this way, I'm going to be the first suspect if she's ever murdered and no one knows who did it, particularly when I know who to contact in terms of her life insurance, and I already have everything planned out in terms of how much I'm going to see her parent, where I'm going to move to, et cetera. But I don't think that that's bad. I really don't. I'm sure none of my plans will probably happen. But just thinking about it I think calms me.
我知道我妻子不同意我的看法。我知道她认为如果我告诉任何人——现在我正在说——我这样想，如果她被谋杀而没人知道是谁干的，我会是第一个嫌疑人，特别是当我知道如何联系人处理她的生命保险时，我已经计划好了一切，关于我多久去见她父母，我要搬到哪里，等等。但我不认为那很坏。我真的不觉得。我敢肯定我的计划大概都不会发生。但仅仅是思考它，我想这让我平静。
To think about it happening and then have it not happen and being glad that it didn't happen I think takes away the fear of it happening a little bit more for me, just in my own mind, thinking I'm dealing with it. OK, that person could die. If I get a little mini fear that the person's not there as I'm climbing up the stairs, maybe my wife is dead in bed, but she's not, and, of course, I get the little mini rush that she wasn't. I also get the feeling that-- it helps calm me, and like, well, look, I could have dealt with it had that been the case, which I think is probably foolish, but yeah.
思考它发生，然后它没发生，并为它没发生而感到高兴，我想这稍微减轻了我对它发生的恐惧，只是在我自己的脑海里，认为我在处理它。好的，那个人可能会死。如果我在爬楼梯时有一点点害怕那个人不在那里，也许我妻子死在床上了，但她没有，当然，我有一点点她没死的快乐冲动。我也有一种感觉，它帮助我冷静，比如，好吧，看，如果那样的话我也能处理。这可能很愚蠢，但确实如此。
Do you have any plans for people you're not related to?
你对非亲属的人有什么计划吗？
Yeah. There's been friends of mine who-- yes. No, I do. There's been friends of mine, male friends, I have pictured dying, and I think about what type of relationship I would maintain with their wives and their kids. Would I step in and try and do a lot in terms of like-- I don't know what. Taking these kids to ball games? Obviously, I would never take the place of their father. Or would I just pay my respects and let the wives come to me if they needed any help?
有。有些我的朋友……是的。不，我有。有些我的男性朋友，我想象过他们去世，我也想过我会和他们的妻子及孩子们维持什么样的关系。我会插手去努力做很多事情，比如……我不知道。带这些孩子去看球赛？显然，我永远不会取代他们父亲的位置。还是我只会致以敬意，如果她们需要任何帮助，就让妻子们来找我？
I do think now that my friend's dad died, I thought-- I had pictured his dad dying prior to him dying because he had had a heart attack prior to the heart attack that killed him. And I thought that my friend would need a lot of support, a lot of attention, but I ended up not doing much. A few phone calls-- it's very strange. A few phone calls I made to him initially to talk about it, and then we would continue to talk, and I'd make a point to call him every week. But I never wanted to talk about the fact that his dad had just died. I did not want to talk about that with him. I wanted to ignore it and just get beyond it. And he would bring it up a few times and bring up a few stories and stuff, but I think-- I remember thinking to myself, this is horrible. I should be able to talk to him about his dad dying, but for whatever reason, it was too difficult.
我现在确实认为，我朋友的父亲去世时，我想……我在他去世前就构想过他父亲会去世，因为他在杀死他的心脏病发作之前有过一次心脏病发作。我认为我朋友会需要很多支持、很多关注，但我最后并没有做太多。几个电话……这很奇怪。最初我给他打过几个电话谈论这件事，然后我们继续谈话，我还会每周给他打电话。但我从不想谈论他父亲刚刚去世的事。我不想和他谈那个。我想忽略它，只是跨过去。他偶尔会提几次，讲几个故事之类的，但我记得当时想，这太可怕了。我应该能和他谈论他父亲去世的事，但无论出于什么原因，这太困难了。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. I mean, it kind of runs counter to my free-flowing thought process of when people die, I'm going to do this. I'm not scared to think or, in this case, talk about it. But I think I just expected myself to be giving him a little more support.
是的。我的意思是，当人们去世时，这有点违背我自由流动的想法——我会这样做。我不怕思考，或者在这种情况下，谈论它。但我认为我只是期待自己能多给他一点支持。
And when you're kind of thinking about these plans like through to the will I move, will I get another job, that kind of stuff, do you then also think about, like, through all the way to the end and then plan for the moment that I think everybody goes through to a certain extent when they're mourning when you have to let go of that person? Do you ever think about that?
当你构想这些计划，比如“我会搬走吗”、“我会换份工作”之类的，你也会一路想到终点，然后计划那种我想每个人在哀悼时都会经历的时刻，当你必须放手那个人时？你也会想到那个吗？
No. Nope, I don't. I don't. I don't think about that at all. I think that is a scarier thought to me, honestly, thinking about letting somebody go. If I ever got to a point in my life where I just said OK, I'm not going to think about Julie or Lisa or Gina or Martin or my mom anymore because the mourning's over and I just kind of have to go on, that would be [SMACKS LIPS]. So no, I would hope that would never happen to me.
不。没有，我没有。我一点也没想到。老实说，那对我来说是一个更可怕的想法，想到要放手某人。如果我生命中达到那样一个点，我说“好的，我不再想朱莉、丽莎、吉娜、马丁或我妈了”，因为哀悼结束了，我不得不继续前行，那会是……不，我希望这永远不会发生在我身上。
Julie Snyder.
朱莉·斯奈德。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself with Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rocklin, Elise Spiegel and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production out from Todd Bachmann and Starlee Kine.
嗯，我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格和我自己制作，还有苏珊·伯顿、布鲁·切维尼、南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·洛克林、埃莉斯·斯皮格尔和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。托德·巴赫曼和斯塔莉·基恩负责制作。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
If you would like to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, (312) 832-3380. Or you know you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website www.thisamericanlife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs the site.
如果您想购买本节目或我们任何节目的盒带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ，(312) 832-3380。或者您知道您可以在我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org 上免费收听我们的大多数节目。感谢运营该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信用]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who has this response to every show: "My god, this is so boring!"
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他对每个节目的回应都是：“天哪，这太无聊了！”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with my stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的故事。
"I'm still bowling on Fridays with the senior citizens."
“我星期五还在和老年人一起打保龄球。”
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。